[Music]
so hear me out let's pitch two giant
dragons against each other one from the
franchise of A Song of Ice and Fire you
know the Game of Thrones and the house
of the Dragon Universe and then another
dragon from the animated How to Train
Your Dragon franchise let's take a look
at two of their largest flying dragons
from both of the shows and compare them
to one another let's take in vegar the
second largest dragon from Westeros and
put it against the Red Death the second
largest dragon from Burke or you know
the dragon archipelago let's take a look
at both of these she dragon sizes their
speeds powers and personality and
compare them against one another so
let's get to it let's begin with the
description so the Red Death this Dragon
was seen in the first How to Train Your
Dragon movie and it was a g gigantic
Beast that is bluish in coloration with
accents and highlights of red all over
the body it has six eyes and an enormous
head with a large mouth that can fit an
entire Viking ship inside of it its
teeth are like swords it has four legs
and massive Wings which enables it to
fly at fast speeds its body tapers out
in a long tail that is equipped with a
club-like ending vagar from the house of
the Dragon though is the biggest dragon
in that series and the second biggest
dragon after barion in the entire
timeline and it was originally one of
the three dragons from aegon's Conquest
this dragon is greenish in coloration
and has a serpentine likee body much
like the rest of its skin she has a
waven body meaning she has two legs and
two arms that are evolved or modified
into massive Wings its tail is long and
snake likee but without any protrusions
or spikes at the end so let's take a
look at their sizes the Red Death is one
of the largest dragons from the dragon
franchise it is set to measure 122 M or
400 ft ft long and would stand around 30
m or 100 ft tall on all four legs its
massive Wings spread out outwards to
around 300 ft or 90 M on both directions
meaning it has a wingspan of around 600
ft or 180 M wide vagar on the other hand
if we take in the officially stated
sizes then she would come in at 150 M or
492 ft long from the head to the tail
with that length and her Serpentine body
she would also stand around 100 ft or 30
m tall but then her wingspan would
stretch out to an impressive 300 M or
almost 1,000 ft wide almost doubling the
wingspan of the Red Death so with the
wingspan in mind let's take a look at
their speed so the Red Death showed no
lack of speed during flight as it was
fast enough to catch up with Toothless
in the air however it's quite possible
that toothless only slowed down to make
the Red Death stay close or that his
prosthetic uh tail fin wasn't allowing
the Night Fury to fly at maximum speed
at that time but even then lacking
agility the Red Death could still fly
pretty fast vagar on the other hand was
also a very proficient flyer and can use
her massive Wings to pursue and maneuver
and even catch the younger ax in midair
but then again irx was young and stupid
and a clumsy Dragon you know at its time
of death so all in all I would say that
both the red de and vagar even though
massive creatures they are are equally F
in the air now let's take a look at
their powers the body of the Red Death
is heavily armored with dense SK horns
and a coral-like frill enabling the
Titanic Beast to perforate pierce as
well as demolish enormous Rock Cliffs of
the volcano and the smaller mountains on
its side not only with brutal
destructive power but the Queen of
Dragons also has been shown to have
incredible stamina in Flight despite her
tremendous size being able to keep up
with the Night Fury she possesses
immense strength capable of effortlessly
lifting Viking ships in her mouth and
then crushing them with one single bite
her methane based flame Jets are
powerful enough to take down an entire
fleet of Viking ships she has six eyes
which gives her no blind spots at all
and can command an entire Army of
dragons with her Alpha call and to top
it all she can inhale a huge amount of
air effectively creating a vacuum to
suck in lesser dragons into her mouth
vagar also has powerful scales that can
protect it from fire blast and Claw
attacks from other smaller dragons she
has a powerful fire breath that can burn
ships to Cinder in a short amount of
time even though we haven't seen this
yet we can infer that this is the case
since drogon a smaller dragon can do the
same thing she possesses incredible
stamina despite her age which is nearing
200 years or two centuries she also has
large claws on her legs but that's about
all of her powers which is basically
just size a good speed and a fire breath
as for experience in battle the red
deaths to athane her status as an alpha
of the dragons in the first movie would
have had quite a number of years
battling other dragons and given that
the the archipelago is filled with
Dragons of all shapes and sizes she
would have had countless battles for
dominance as well as hunting other
dragons for food vagar also has had
quite a lot of fights in her 200 years
but these battles are quite often
against smaller dragons which she can
easily overpower with her massive size
and large mouth but then both these
dragons though were defeated by smaller
competitors the Red Death met her end
against toothless denight Fury which
employed a hit and run tactic burning
the wing membranes until she fell to her
death from the sky vagar also met a
similar end Bing coraxis a smaller
Dragon which employed a swooping
maneuver and caus both the dragons to
plumble to death in rook's rest but this
battle was more intense as both caraxes
and Vega were locked in on each other's
throats till the final
crash so if we do a comparison we would
find that vagar has an edge in size but
this would not be a huge advantage since
the Red Death even though she is sh in
length is more robustly built and has a
larger head for bites the four legs of
the Red Death are also armed with deadly
claws that can rip vagar body to shreds
if they are locked in close quarters
fights vegar might also have large claws
but they would not be enough to counter
the hard armed scales of the other
dragon and given that the Red Death also
has a club tail this fight would be
heavily tilted to bur's dragon in a
Range fire breath battle both would have
equally strong Flames which cannot be
Quantified so well as to see how much
damage they could inflict on each other
but this eventually would lead to a
melee battle again a battle that the Red
Death would easily win so in this
comparison the Red Death beats
vagar so that's about all we have about
vear and the Red Death and their
comparison so if you like this video
then watch just other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
content we might just have things you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care
fam